well I think we've been programmed quite
a bit with our relationship with money
we have a relationship with everything
known in our environment you have a
relationship a neurological Network in
your brain to for your parents for your
cell phone for your computer for the
most part the brain is a reflection of
everything that we know along with that
is our relationship with money and I
feel like I have a really good
relationship with money because I work
on having a really good relationship
with everything in my life and so let's
back up and just look at how people form
beliefs because yes most beliefs are
created from past experiences right
children when they're in their early
ages their brain waves are very slow
like their brain waves are in Alpha when
they're like seven to twelve they're in
Theta when they're like two to six years
old and they're in Delta like when
they're newborn to two years old and so
these brainwave states are states that
were really suggestible to information
so when we hear information we believe
it and we accept it we believe it we
surrender to it as if it's the truth
without analyzing it because there's no
analytical facilities yet the analytical
mind starts around 12 or so 7 to 12 and
that analytical mind is actually what
creates a barrier between the conscious
mind and the subconscious mind hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make the make
these videos because the thing that
saved me as an entrepreneur was watching
the stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
learn how to use it or lose it with Joe
dispenza enjoy
if you heard money is the root of all
evil
money is bad
only certain people are allowed to make
money you have to work hard to make
money this is how you got to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like write
recording an audio file you just keep
recording that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right so a lot of
people have a relationship with money
based on either what they've been told
or what they've experienced in their
outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame and
takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory So based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion Alters our
internal state so you're going along as
Lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal State and your
senses get heightened and then you
freeze the frame and you associate this
internal state with whatever it is
that's causing it right and that's how
we create long-term memories right so
our painful memories more uh powerful or
beautiful memories more powerful uh
they're both equal okay they're both
equal but but the problem is I think
most people experience from more than
negative the emotions right and those
are negative motions really are derived
from the hormones of stress right so the
alarm system the emergency system
creates an arousal you know inwardly and
that arousal saying there's something
dangerous in your outer environment
right and it could be a person a
circumstance an accident or whatever and
that that change in emotional state
causes you to remember the event you
gotta pay attention right you got to
stay really and narrow your focus on the
cause
so so think about people who have
relationships with money right from the
past with all beliefs are based on past
experiences so you have an experience
where you lose money you have an
experience where money's taken away from
you have an experience where you don't
have enough you're living in a place
where there's not enough money or a
family that's not enough money then the
emotion that most people are living by
in a moment-to-moment basis is lack like
I'm in lack of having something that I
want okay now there's nothing wrong with
that because the experience changes your
emotional state you freeze the frame you
take a picture the problem is
that's hardware so we think
neurologically within the circuits of
that past experience and we feel
chemically within the boundaries of that
emotion which would say for example be
lack right so now the person says before
you go on to the next thing what happens
to the body in the mind when it is in an
environment of lack mentally or
physically I'm in lack what is what is
the body to mind saying yes so the body
is saying I'm waiting
for some external event to occur
I win the lottery I marry the right guy
whatever it is that you're waiting for
that event to occur that experience
produces an emotion so the emotion then
takes away the lack
and so when we play the game in
three-dimensional reality the creation
game in three-dimensional reality we
experience separation from everyone and
everything because our our senses fool
us into the illusion the hallucination
of Separation I'm here and you're there
I'm here and the door is over there so
I'm aware that I'm here at one point of
Consciousness and the door is over there
another point of Consciousness okay so
in order for me to get from here to the
door I gotta move my body and do
something through space I gotta do
something and everything in this
three-dimensional reality is going to
take time and energy right so okay so
then here's here's Lewis right here and
then he says okay I want this experience
in my future and your brain
automatically predicts and projects how
far in the future you think it's going
to take maybe it's a year five years ten
years 30 years oh my God right because
that's what it's going to take to pay
off that house right so now one point of
Consciousness I'm here the other point
of Consciousness is where I'm placing my
dreams so I mean separate from that
experience so then how do I get to that
experience in three-dimensional reality
you got to get up and you got to do
something you gotta go to work you gotta
drive to work it takes energy you got to
fill your car with gas you got to eat
food you got to work you know all this
stuff you got to sleep you got to
recover with your stress and now people
are
in a sense waiting for the experience
that's 10 years down the road or 30
years down the world to happen to take
away the lack of them not having it and
unfortunately many times when the
experience finally occurs they can't
enjoy it because they're too exhausted
right so then so you play the game you
you go to school you study really hard
or you study on your own you develop
some skills you make the right choices
you start saving money you start
learning from your mistakes and then the
game is how many things can you
accumulate and that accumulation then
you associate with being wealthy or
being abundant or being successful right
and some people get really good at it
right you can get really good at that
but for the most part though
when we create from three-dimensional
reality we're creating from lack and
separation in other words you're driving
down the road and you see someone
driving a car that all of a sudden you
realize that you don't have the moment
you become aware that that person has
that car and you don't have it you're in
lack of having it right so what the
brain naturally does is it naturally
creates you driving that car and you
have an image of yourself driving that
car and you start identifying wow that
would be a greater experience for me to
have
the problem is the distance between the
thought of what you want
and the experience of actually happening
it happening for most people is the
concept called time right between cause
and effect right so some people develop
the ability to manage themselves and
manage their life develop certain skills
and they can pay for it and they can get
it very quickly the problem is when the
novelty of that experience wears off you
know the car and they're no longer
identifying with that and the feeling of
emptiness and lack comes back they need
to find something else to find something
else and so there's this game that goes
on where you never have enough right and
that's the lack game right
so then if you think about people having
the things they want in their life when
they create from lack and separation
it's the experience in three-dimensional
reality that produces the emotion and
the emotion is saying let's feel that
experience this thing that you've been
in lack and separation from and that
emotion then takes away the lack of
Separation but you've worked really hard
to get it okay nothing wrong with that
is there another way to do it yes okay
so
the person who's living in lack is
waiting for their wealth to feel
abundant
they're waiting for their success to
feel empowered they're waiting for their
healing to feel gratitude they're
waiting for their new relationship to
feel love they're waiting for the
mystical experience to feel awe that's
the Newtonian model of reality of cause
and effect you know waiting for that
event to happen to take away this
separation or lack nothing wrong with it
it's the way most people create but what
we've discovered is actually something
else
the moment you feel gratitude your
Healing Begins the moment you feel
worthy and abundant you're generating
wealth the moment you're empowered you
are moving towards your success the
moment you're in love with yourself and
you're in love with life you'll create
an equal the moment you are in awe of
life you're going to have a mystical
experience and so that's causing an
effect right
so then if you can teach people then
how to create instead of from lack or
separation but create from wholeness
and create from what we call the quantum
field
instead of three-dimensional reality
what's the difference Okay so
the way you first of all it takes
knowledge okay the quantum field is an
invisible field of energy that exists
beyond our senses you can't see it you
can't smell it you can't taste it you
can't hear it you can't feel it it
exists beyond our experience of
three-dimensional reality would this be
in the our minds Consciousness or would
this be in a different space okay let's
let's look at that so the answer to the
question is how much of your waking day
do you put your attention on matter on
the material world
and how much of your waking day are you
aware of energy and frequency for most
people they're unaware of the quantum
field and if you're unaware of it
it doesn't exist for you just like you
have a nose but if you're unaware of it
it doesn't exist for you the moment you
become aware of it exists well the
quantum field you can ask you can study
all kinds of Science and they'll tell
you there is this invisible field of
frequency and energy that exists beyond
the senses that tend to connect
everything physical and material in fact
everything physical and material is
connected to this field rule number two
is prime your brain the think box is so
important because we have to
review our act we have to repeat it
enough times and the act of mental
rehearsal really installs the
neurological Hardware in your brain it
primes the brain free so you have
circuits to use now mental rehearsal
also changes the body you can take a
group of men uh and have them imagine or
rehearse doing bicep curls for an hour a
day for two weeks and add an emotional
component called stronger harder more
intense and for one hour they practice
in their mind doing those those curls at
the end of two weeks there's a 13.5
increase in muscle strength they never
lifted weight their bodies changing by
thought alone so the person who's
priming their brain and body through
rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities they're analytical
mind is out of the way and they can they
can sustain a state where nothing in
their environment is going to move them
from the state they're in the feeling of
what it would feel like to play well and
they hold on to that feeling and when
the conditions get tense they actually
do something different they
self-regulate and they actually crave
this moment of performance to be able to
produce an outcome and so there's no
mysticism to this it's just what people
do when they get really into something
is that we rehearse all the time so when
people understand if you take a group of
people have never played the piano
before and you teach them one hand that
scales them chords and they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you do a
brain stand and before and after they'll
grow circuits on the opposite side of
the brain no magic there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get your body involved you
get some instruction you have an
experience experience enriches the
circuits repeat it over and over again
fire and wire and pay attention and stay
present you'll assemble new neurological
circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes and actually have them
mentally rehearse playing the scales and
chords for two hours a day for five days
scan their brain before and after and
the end of five days their brain will
look like they've been playing the piano
for five days but they never lifted a
finger the brain literally changed
through the rehearsal okay so now take
the person and put them in front of a
piano never played the piano before and
they could actually play those scales
and chords like the people who are
actually physically demonstrating it so
what does that have to do for the single
mother of three children what does that
have to do with the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living or conditioning your body
and brain into the future against 15
hours of you and responding emotionally
from your past so we got to rehearse
okay how am I going to be in this
situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because there's not a time to create
it's not a time to learn it's not a time
to go inward it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time in the arousal of those stress
hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
uh to anything in their environment even
on a microscopic level also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free work
the worksheet will highlight all the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three is welcome
change everybody secretly wants to
evolve and have a new experience they
whether it's wealth whether it's Health
whether it's a new relationship whether
it's a new career everybody has in their
mind some vision of where they want to
be in the future there's there's nothing
wrong with that
and and our simple model is that
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called in life which
means that if you want to change your
life you want to create a new person in
reality you're gonna have to change your
personality you're going to have to
change because nothing changes in your
life until you change so what is the
understanding of change that we've spent
over 10 years studying a way to explain
what change is because
if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts or
however many thoughts in one day and
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before you're
in trouble because the same thoughts
will lead to the same choices the same
choices will lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce those very same emotions and
those same emotions influence our same
thoughts and our biology our neural
circuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones or gene expression
our immune to everything stays the same
because we're the same so it has
traditionally taken crisis or trauma or
loss for someone to make up their mind
to change so the moment we decide to
change okay I want to create a new
personal reality a new life
I got to change my personality well this
concept called metacognition we have
four brain function you know the seat of
our conscience our frontal lobe allows
us to think about what we're thinking
about to notice how we're behaving and
and to become aware of how we're feeling
and
the the repetition of thinking acting
and feeling in the same way causes our
brain to become hardwired into very
specific neural patterns right so that
that that firing and wiring over time
cause us causes us to be happen so
automatically that we're unconscious
of our conscious self so the moment we
become conscious of those thoughts the
moment we become aware of those
behaviors the moments we notice those
feelings we're no longer the program in
fact where the Consciousness observing
the program and that's the first step to
change so when you decide
and become so conscious the word
meditation I looked it up
the symbol means to become familiar with
that's all it means it means
familiarization so if you become so
familiar with I can it's too hard I'll
never change no one loves me you become
aware that you are blaming complaining
you all all day long and talking trash
about somebody you notice all of a
sudden that this feeling that you're
feeling every single day that you're so
accustomed to is really guilt or shame
or unworthiness the moment you're
conscious of what what you're
experiencing in other words when you're
inside the jar you can't read the label
right so you gotta become conscious of
that unconsciousness you've got to see
yourself Through The Eyes of someone
else the tragedy that causes you to no
longer feel like you any longer actually
causes you to look at you from the eyes
of someone else you can see yourself
more clearly because you're not feeling
like you any longer that's the
that's the big moment of change so then
when a person really can become so
conscious of their unconscious self that
they don't go unconscious again or let
me say it another way how many times do
we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
right so we default back to our old
personality every single day because we
respond to someone or something in our
outer environment and I say so
um why are you unhappy today and you say
oh I am happy I'm unhappy today because
of that person or that circumstance it's
never one thing Dr Joe it's always like
10 things
yeah it's just 10 things right but but
you would say I'm this way because of
these 10 things but what that really
means from biological standpoint
is that something in your outer
environment
is actually controlling the way you're
feeling and the way you're thinking now
anything that's controlling your feel
controlling the way you feel and think
you're victim to that circumstance and
the stronger the emotion you feel for
that condition or that problem or that
person the more you pay attention to
them and where you place your attention
is where you place your energy and
you're giving your power away to that
person or service and that that could
could also be I mean that is true and I
think we all know this of you know like
a diagnosis and that meaning that I mean
the the 12-step terminology is like you
can make anything your higher power
right
um You you can make a diagnosis a
judgment of you the way your parents you
know taught you to think about yourself
those things can be essentially what you
worship and that then is this you know
kind of self perpetuating I mean
literally self-perpetuating Loop exactly
everybody has done this
and at some point in their life right
where they have to catch the thought
they have to catch their how they speak
the ACT they have to notice oh this is
that weird feeling again I'm not gonna
just stay in this feeling can I change
it right so then if you remind yourself
every single day of who you no longer
want to be before you start your day
become conscious of your unconscious
self so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious in your waking day the
next fundamental question is if your
personality creates your personal
reality
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and with attention with
presence and intention energy
begin to Fire and wire that thought if
you can fire and wire that thought you
start installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain keep doing it and
start acting acting like a software
program it becomes more automatic that's
the new voice in your head that says you
can it's possible rule number four is
recondition your body how do you create
the life you want and how do you begin
to have you know your subjective mind
produce effects in your objective world
now the quantum model says that the
moment you begin to look for an electron
electron you know is in a field of
probabilities or possibilities and the
Observer comes along and the observer
looks and all of a sudden Boom the
electron appears it collapses from a
wave of possibilities into an event
called collapsing the wave function
that's a Quantum event so mind and
matter are somehow correlated so the
question is can you observe
your life the way you want and cause
infinite patterns of energy to collapse
into new information called the new
experience in your life or a new Quantum
event
so for two years we taught the workshops
around the world and guess what happened
not a lot we didn't see a lot of change
every now and then we see people's lives
were getting better here and there but
what I was after was because when I
wrote what the bleep I understood the
science of changing your mind the
process of change requires unlearning
and relearning
it requires breaking the habit of your
old self and then Reinventing a new self
it's what we say in Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections
unmerizing emotions that are stored in
your body and then reconditioning your
body to a new mind into a new emotion to
deprogram to reprogram to lose your mind
and create a new one
to move your energy out of the past and
then use that energy to drive you to a
new future
and so I saw what people did when they
had spontaneous remissions I saw four
things that they had in common all of
them believed that there was a spiritual
aspect to them something greater that
was giving them life that they wanted to
connect to they wanted to give that
intelligence a plan a template a design
and then surrender it and allow it to do
it for them
and so I began to realize that many many
people in the world were beginning to
embrace this concept of quantum physics
and spirituality the second thing they
had in common is they all understood it
was their mismanagement of their life
that created their disease it was their
20 years of hatred their 30 years of
bitterness through 10 years of guilt
they're 45 years of anger and those
emotions they had memorized and those
emotions were driving certain thoughts
and those thoughts were reaffirming
certain emotions and how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
thoughts are the language of the brain
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates a
state of being but the redundancy of
that cycle of thinking and feeling over
time conditions your body to memorize
that emotional state as well as the
conscious mind and moment the body knows
better than the mind that's called a
habit a habit is when your body is your
mind and 95 percent of Who We Are by the
time we're 35 years old this is science
it's a set of memorized behaviors
emotional reactions beliefs and
perceptions that function like an
unconscious subconscious automatic
program so when people go to change
they're using five percent of their
conscious mind to work against 95
percent of what they've memorized and
they would think positively all they
wanted but they've been memorizing
negativity for the last 25 years where
they create their dream board you know
with their SUV and their hairstyle and
kid in the back and you know fingernails
and house and but they felt unworthy
it's mind and body and opposition
and so I realized that the very emotions
of anger and aggression and hostility
and hatred and frustration and judgment
and fear and anxiety and hopelessness
and powerlessness and depression and
insecurity are all driven by the
hormones of stress and rule number five
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips has become Supernatural we
found out that when people react
emotionally with anger with antagonism
uh there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous systems the
Primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my God
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they flee they're in fear they're like
the fear is I'm better just getting away
so they they Their Fear causes them to
run uh uh so uh when people feel fear
when they feel anger when they feel pain
those are the primary stimulators that
switch on that sympathetic nervous
system and they used to say
that it's automatic like it's automatic
it happens automatically that's part of
the autonomic nervous system and you
really don't have any control of it
turns out that's absolutely not the
truth so first thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and I say Alex why are you so
mad today and you say oh it's because of
this situation and this person this
happened this way and I would say oh my
gosh all right do you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel in the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is now that's okay but if
you keep that emotional reaction going
on
for hours or days and I say to you Alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me I'm I'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago I'd say you
have a mood you're in a mood now some
people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then I would say
well Alex has a angry temperament it
becomes a temperament if we keep it
going for now this is true people keep
this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago yeah
and the research on the memory says that
50 of that story isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story and make it
sound worse than it really was to excuse
themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget the event
doesn't matter the details of the event
doesn't what matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused
and it starts getting frustrated and it
starts getting angry and people say I'm
doing my meditation wrong you know what
I say to them no no no no you're doing
it right because that has to come up so
then
so when the younger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if I teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and I teach you a
way to change that
every time you settle the body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger
that's a victory because you're telling
the body it's no longer the mind that
you're the mind now it'll go well yeah
well what about this circumstance and
what about that and it'll get aroused
again
and then you notice it and instead of
turning on the TV or getting on your
cell phone or getting on the social
media
you lower the volume again now this is
the work
it turns out every time you do that that
Victory you're telling the body that
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and then all of a sudden wants to
get up and go it's busy it's got things
to do and it's and and you become aware
that it wants to do that and you bring
it back to the present moment you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program now
turns out if you do this enough times
sooner or later the body surrenders
sooner the later the body acquiesces it
says I'm no longer the mind
Alex is the mind and when that occurs
there's a liberation of energy that
anger
that frustration literally turns into
energy it's released into the field as
information now you return back into
your life and you see the same person or
the same circumstance your response to
them is going to be much less why
because you took care of it within you
well you're not trying to fix it out
there just that your response is
different so now if you're no longer
responding to the environment and your
response to the environment isn't
weakening the organism because stress
depletes energy
then you're less susceptible to the
environment and we found out that when
people do this their immune system gets
so robust
that you can take viruses like SARS cov2
virus and subject that virus to the
plasma of advanced meditators and
there's a resistance to the right the
virus doesn't enter the cell why because
there's energy
for there's energy to be able to combat
it so so it's because the person is not
reacting so that shortening your
response
to that condition is a victory and it
takes practice and so then how many
times
do we have to forget and go unconscious
and be angry so we decide to no longer
forget and keep remembering and stay
conscious that's change right there so
we use meditation as a model to remind
ourselves who we're going to be when we
open our eyes and to remind ourselves
who are no longer going to be when we
open our eyes and stay so conscious of
it that we don't go unconscious in our
waking day and if we do it properly
then there's feedback in our life that
shows us that you've changed and
remember nothing changes
in your life until you change
if you want to have more money one way
is to uncover the areas where you may be
wasting money and that's why we're
talking about five common ways we throw
money away where exactly did your money
go money is something a lot of us
struggle with check this out in a 2019
employee survey a PWC 71 of Millennials
said their money stress had gone up over
the past year it is stressing me out and
nearly half of all respondents said that
they spend three hours or more every
week thinking about or trying to sort
out their finances and money woes don't
just affect us individually 44 of young
adults said that the money is the number
one stressor in their relationship
and check out these stats according to
Erin Lowry creator of the broke
Millennial Blog the average Millennial
graduated with 37 000 in student debt
that's in the states and some have much
more that's enough to buy a brand new
car or put a down payment on a house
maybe you're like yeah don't remind me
Jay hey I get it lots of Us come from
tough places financially and you might
be there now growing up my family
definitely was not what you'd call
wealthy for some of us the hard times
actually help spur us on to success
here's one of the stories that's really
inspired me it's of a young man who at
14 was evicted with his mother from
their apartment and couldn't afford a
place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success you
remind himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that that's why he named his company
seven bucks Productions still even if
you don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
Suz Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested that 100 or more
per month so many of us spend on coffee
in a lost retirement account over 40
years with compound interest you'd have
a million dollars what that's worth
making your own coffee right actually
the entire category of food and drink is
a big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520
B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends two thousand seven
hundred and forty six dollars per year
on lunches now check this out if instead
of buying lunch you invested that money
every month in a basic savings account
over 20 years you'd have hope you're
sitting down because this is
unbelievable you'd have sixty thousand
seven hundred and sixty dollars and 41
cents I'm gonna sit down and that's just
basic compounding interest okay so
here's another big way we raise money
buying new now here's the thing I know
for lots of us I'll be honest myself
included how we look is important we
enjoy fashion but you can continue to
have your unique look and have favorite
Brands and still spend less money on
clothing here's a way to do that I have
another friend who's into designer
Brands but would never pay designer
prices her secret is to shop at
consignment stores and now that there
are lots of these stores online there
are tons of items to choose from and you
can even shop by your favorite Brands
the other month I complimented my friend
on a sweater and she told me she got it
for 65 less than the original price and
it came brand new with the tag still
attached plus shopping Consignment also
benefits the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff Beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to for
example if your iPhone breaks you can
actually buy a refurbished one directly
from Apple for way less money and they
come with a warranty and don't get me
started on cars here's another quiz when
you drive a new car off the lot it
literally immediately loses a certain
percentage of its value what percentage
is it a five percent B 10 or C 30 the
answer is B according to Carfax the
second you drive a new car off the lot
it loses at least 10 percent in value
over the first year it loses about 20 of
its value that means if you spend thirty
thousand dollars on a brand new car
within a year it's worth only twenty
four thousand dollars and the value just
keeps going down instead of needing
everything brand new look at what you
can buy used or borrowed from someone
you know and that's another way we waste
money we buy things immediately we think
of it we get all excited we go online
and buy it it's like when the app Apple
watch first came out and I went out and
bought one I was so stoked but no
offense to the product I discovered
pretty quickly just in time to give it
back that I didn't actually need it I
ended up returning it
take it back instead of impulse buying
virtual purchases if you say oh I need
to buy that whatever it may be and then
go to Amazon and buy it and then later
in the day I wanted to get some of that
other thing I loved and then going to
Amazon or another store to buy that what
happens when you get your card statement
it all adds up and you're like whoa how
did I spend that much money I don't
remember any of that and that's because
fifteen dollars here and ten dollars
there doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment but you
don't see the money you don't feel it
you don't actually have that experience
of giving it away or holding on to it
instead when you think of something you
need and I'm putting need in quotes
because it might not be a real need but
a want put it in your cart and leave it
there or write it down on a list don't
buy it right away then at some specified
time like the end of the week look at
your list all your cards and choose what
it is you really need that will give you
a better idea of what you're actually
spending and what you actually need
versus what you want another way we
waste money is by passing up free money
a court and you're and you're wondering
what are you talking about according to
investment advisors Financial engines
American employees leave roughly 24
billion dollars on the table every year
in unclaimed money by not taking full
advantage of their employer match on
their 401K the typical employee loses
out a 1 336 dollars per year now look if
your boss said hey we'd like to just
give you 1 336 dollars per year you'd be
like yes please right I'm gonna need
that in cash but if you're not
contributing the full percentage that an
employer will match you're basically
saying No thank you so you need to stop
missing out on free money going back to
your book I think that one thing that's
really really interesting about it is
the way that you structure it around
like 80 of the book is the excuses that
you you literally tackle them one one by
one that was really smart and then skill
acquisition yeah so why why that
structure why excuses and skills because
of that well the excuses are just what I
hear all day from women in DMS and
emails standing in line at a book
signing it's all the reasons why they
can't do what they want to do and
um it makes my head explode because it's
like what like you're not ugh it drives
me crazy so I thought it's well and good
for us to talk about the things that you
need to do to achieve this stuff but
none of this matters if you don't have
this foundational
like presence of mind to get out of your
own way and to stop using that as a
crutch for why you can't do what you
want to do if I get Flack for anything
in this space it's the idea that I tell
women that anybody can accomplish
anything and I really believe that to
the marrow of my bones because there is
no reason that I should have the life
that I have the business I've built the
being on St like I shouldn't have any of
this this is working every single day
for the last 15 years to achieve the
thing that I want to achieve you had
said something recently or maybe it was
on your Instagram where someone said
like how do I become a speaker and you
were like speak everywhere everyone that
go everywhere
that people like oh I would love to be a
speaker but I can never talk like you
and I'm like I spoke at Old Folks homes
I spoke because they can't run away by
the way if anyone needs this tip the
people laugh I'm like no it was for real
mops groups which is mothers of
preschoolers as they exist all over the
country I'd speak at the opening of an
envelope and I was horrible like my
first speeches it was this maybe
something it was like
and it's so embarrassing and you know
your hands are shaking and I had note
cards and I keep the videos on YouTube
because I want people to see the
progression of what a decade looks like
I've done it so much I mean you need to
do a keynote right now I got you I can
make it up but it didn't start that way
it was so many years and so much effort
and the problem is people don't they're
like well I can't because or here's the
reason why I'm like yeah me too I had
all those excuses and it didn't mean
that making the decision to move forward
suddenly it got easier if anything
making the decision to move forward is
harder like because now
um John Maxwell said this to me the
other day he's like which is the most
name dropping thing but I was
interviewing him on the podcast we're
not like you know having a slumber party
but he said
um movement causes friction always and
so it's you it just because you make the
decision to move forward doesn't mean it
you know now we're now we're doing it no
now you've got all kinds of other
problem so excuses were really important
for me to tackle just because I think
love my girls but women especially like
we need to call BS and you need to have
someone get in your face and say like
with all the love in my heart this is
not this is not real this is something
that you've decided to cling to because
it justifies why you're still in the
same place if you're living in the past
you're going to be depressed because you
are rehashing things that happen to you
that are not going to happen again if
you're living in the future you're going
to be anxious because you are
anticipating what's coming or you're
wishing for things that aren't happening
yet being in the present is where the
gold is being in the present moment is
where you will have the greatest control
where you will feel the most at ease and
where happiness
flourishes there's a super tight
connection between happiness and the
ability to live in the present moment a
lot of people believe that happiness is
tied to the things that happen to you
not so at all in fact there is a
professor of positive psychology he's
one of the grandfathers of the movement
he teaches at the University of
Pennsylvania his name is Martin
settleman and he studied happiness for
decades now one of the things that we've
talked about a lot is that 40 percent of
your happiness levels are preset by
genetics
sixty percent you are in complete
control of and one of the things that
this professor has has discovered is
that it doesn't matter what's happened
to you in fact some of the people that
have had the worst things the worst
things happen to them like people that
have survived the Holocaust are actually
the happiest and most grateful people in
the world
happiness comes down to this right up
here comes down to your thoughts comes
down to your mindset it comes down to
your attitude and you are 100 control of
what you're thinking
you may not be in control of how you
feel in the moment but you can always
always always always be in control of
what you think and that will change how
you're feeling one of the most powerful
things that you can do in terms of think
and this gets back to strick's question
is how do you be present being present
is literally nothing more than the skill
of having your thoughts be in this
moment not in the past not in the future
but right here the way that you teach
yourself how to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself being distracted the moment you
catch yourself starting to worry the
moment you catch yourself drifting to
the Future drifting to the past that's a
moment of tremendous power because you
basically just woke up you basically
just notice that you're not here in this
particular moment
so use that wake-up call 54321 and
ground Yourself In This Moment
best way to ground yourself in the
moment is to look for something in this
particular moment that you can Savor now
I'm using the word saver on purpose
because it's the word that psychologists
use to describe what happens when you
find something in this moment right now
right here right now to focus on and to
appreciate it could be literally the
questions these are these are printed
out questions from people on social
media and if I were to stop and look at
these and Savor them what I would feel
in this moment is a tremendous amount of
gratitude because people are taking the
time to write and that makes me feel
incredibly grateful and it also makes me
very happy because it means that that
the folks that are writing are taking
control of their lives and seeking out
the information that they need another
form of savoring that we can all relate
to is eating as you're eating instead of
drifting to the Future and thinking
about all the things that you need to do
or hanging out in the past and rehashing
everything that's happened during the
day be in this moment in this meal
slow down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with and how you feel about them
and if you want to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge them hey this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
I'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
the small simple acts of savoring are
how you expand your happiness inside the
present moment so how do you be more
present
simple
the moment that you catch yourself in
the future in the past worrying whatever
refocus yourself right here right now
and then find something right here right
now that you can savor
and when you do that you're not only
going to be present you're going to feel
more grateful and you're going to feel a
little boost of Happiness the tax
department which every country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for
So when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent a parent to the
child
they say it's go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here and the first
thing you pay is the highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees or
invest
so earned income is what they work for
the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if I buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand a hundred
thousand is capital gains if I buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest tax so
the tax breaks that President Trump is
working on today is primarily for these
guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
Highly Educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff are
flipping houses you get a break
but what the really which work for
is
passive income and passive income
[Applause]
for me I have a business whether I work
or not money comes in
and you've seen me I'm not here am I no
I never never
I've heard the right not to be here real
estate I get milk every year my wife and
I can we add more real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still get this but
this is another type of income
this here I'll get into is called
Phantom income it's taxes I don't pay so
there's a little bit beyond most
people's minds but let's say my tax bill
is a hundred thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means
fifty thousand in taxes I don't have to
pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what Financial education does
it teaches you about the financial
statement which is not taught in school
again they teach you FICO scores which
is really fight those scores
was you told Lil Dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now ironically
when you save money Ava 401k
this is the kind of income so Savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better it's the saving money in
what he called it 401 cases good okay in
this in Canada it's called rrsp in
Australia called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
I'm an active investor I don't buy this
because this is passive investors I am
active and I'm professional in all of
these areas
so I work for passive income which means
I'm not here the check comes in the
checks come in every year and you've
seen Kim and I and your mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up and they
don't have a job what is Max out really
stand for for you and when did that
moment happen where you knew that that
was gonna be part of your brand yeah um
my son's name is Max so that helped
um but maxed out to me means this as you
know your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those and so I
became obsessed
um the the short version is is that you
don't know this I don't talk about this
on camera very much when I was 30 my
uncle died at 50 years old and he was
the guy in my family we all have this
that you kind of resemble or remind
everybody of my dad's brother he died at
50. sorry no thank you I appreciate that
it's a long time ago now and um but he
was kind of was my godfather and or my
culture that's a big deal of course
might as well yeah I know shout out to
Uncle Mike yeah mine was Uncle Mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa everywhere
right there whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
Whoa man that's how the universe works
right
wow okay
you got me right there so mine was my
Uncle Mike
wow
and oh man I just touched me
so
mine was my Uncle Mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
I'm on I'm at his funeral we're flying
back on the flight there's this thing in
your brain called the reticular
activating system it basically filters
into your awareness what's important to
you that's why like if you buy a new car
all of a sudden you see that car
everywhere on the freeway three lanes
over on the other side another one they
were always there why do you see them
now filtered into your importance
and heart attacks were at my he had died
of a heart attack and so I'm on the
airplane and I'm listening to music and
on the screens the Oprah show but I'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen I'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at Cedar
signing where they could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short I hear it and I told my
wife I said schedule me for one of those
exams she's like it's expensive I said I
don't care schedule it we call it's a
nine month wait I go I need to get in I
need to get in I keep calling the lady
finally she goes there's a cancellation
tomorrow at two I go I'll be there so I
go down for the scan and thank God this
doctor understood influence and leverage
do you do the scan then you come back
after lunch I literally went ate a
burrito came back I wasn't in shape I'm
30 years old the doctor comes out and he
goes um
um no I'm looking for Edward mylet I go
it's mylet you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
well I can't believe these arteries are
in that younger body wow you need to
come back son
now my heart's racing I'm like what like
what the hell's in the skin we sit down
instead of what a normal doctor would do
they just go hey um here's the
prescription take Crest or work out eat
goodbye he understood reasons is what
changes people's lives massive reasons
not disciplined reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um
uh do you have kids I go yeah I go I got
a son he's one he goes That's great um
do you want to be there when he
graduates high school
I went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school I
said uh yeah he goes okay uh is she
pregnant huh I go yeah what does she
have and I said a girl you get to a dad
this is what you say he goes would you
like to walk that little girl down the
aisle on her wedding day son
I went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes I want to be very clear with
you young man I remember this like
yesterday because I want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's going to live with
your beautiful wife and your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
going to be armed arm with your daughter
on her wedding day not you you'll be
long gone actually as I tell you this
right now dude right and he goes what
I'm going to get you to do is I'm going
to get you to max out your life and your
Fitness
and I went
get me yeah and he gave me exactly what
I needed to do and he said if you do
this you'll walk her down the aisle blah
blah blah from that day when I get up
like I did this morning and I'm tired
and I was late last night and I don't
want to go to the gym I swear to you
brother I swear to you I go Bella's
wedding get your ass up and I go I I'm
fit because I have massive reasons
that's why I'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life I'm like if I can do this in my
fitness I can do this in business I can
do this in my spirituality and
everything I'm not going to shortchange
myself by pretty good I'm going to see
what my real potential is what my
maximum capacity is every single day
because at the end of my life when I do
die I have this belief that when I'm
done the Lord's going to go well done
good and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been this
is the man you were born to be this is
the man you were destined to be this is
where you could have gone but you could
have seen the memories you could have
had the people you could help the person
you could have become and meet him my
obsession is that every day I'm chasing
that dude so that when I do die we meet
we're identical twins because the bad
end of a life whether it would be at 30
50 or 150 would be I meet that guy and
we're total strangers yeah so I'm
obsessed with meeting that guy someday
and that's what maxing out means make
your calendar your life this is how you
start to live an intentional life
because you've designed it you've put it
in your calendar not just the business
things when we think about a calendar
it's usually your business stuff okay I
got a meeting here I gotta I gotta send
my newsletter out I have to whatever the
things are for your business life right
you're if you're an entrepreneur you
probably have some of your business
things put in your calendar I'm not
talking just about that I'm talking
about your life
talking about how do you live an
intentional Life by structuring
every day
what ends up happening inside of that is
oh my gosh that's too much structure I
can't stick to it that's too it's too
overwhelming I need free time I need
free time in my calendar great put free
time in your calendar
if you know that you need two hours a
week to have nothing in your calendar
okay
then when is that gonna happen
this is how you reduce stress and
anxieties because you've actually
scheduled in your two hour break and
nothing else comes in because when you
don't schedule your break here's what
happens
other things are going to come up as a
priority other people's emergencies
other people's phone calls and texts and
emails and social media and then what
does what happens you lead back down to
stress anxiety overwhelm
you block off your time you build your
your ideal life
I was talking entrepreneur yesterday who
I'm mentoring and he he his business
blowing up his business is blowing up
it's amazing
um on his way to seven Figures it's
crazy
and he's struggling with his health
going to doctor's appointments
struggling as lots of inflammation and
it's about you okay so you need to you
need to eat better you need to work out
more you need to have a kind of healthy
lifestyle you you already know this I'm
not telling you anything new
but it's on his calendar
so we loaded his calendar and his
calendar is all of his business stops
like okay well where are you where is
the physical activity in your calendar
and where are you prepping for the meals
that you're going to eat because when
you just show up on a good morning hey
have a great day awesome okay now you're
really hungry there's nothing healthy in
the fridge what do you do you go for you
go for junk or you go do takeout
because you didn't plan because it
wasn't in your calendar
you need to schedule it you need to
schedule when you're going to go buy
food if you're going to order out how
many times a week you want to order out
like schedule this stuff in as Jocko
willing says discipline equals freedom
you want this life it's entirely
possible
but you have to have the discipline in
your calendar to actually follow through
on it
when you find yourself not following the
calendar
it's because of a couple reasons the
first is because
you set goals that are not actually
possible there wasn't enough flexibility
in your calendar right that you say how
many times you've set a goal and he said
I'm going to work out every day for for
two hours and then and then what happens
you don't because it's unrealistic
because that's not gonna happen
and what you're also doing is training
yourself that you suck that when you set
goals that you don't follow through
that's a problem
then the next time you set a goal you're
gonna
tell yourself oh I'm not going to do
this one either because I always set
goals and don't follow through you don't
you stop believing in yourself it's not
even other people believing in you you
don't believe in yourself because you've
taught yourself that when you do some
when you say you're going to do
something you don't actually do it
that's a problem
so how do we start to fix that we start
to fix that by actually creating a
calendar that reflects her entire life
so think about your goals let's let's
break this down right step one think
about the life that you want what's the
life that you want
how much time do you want to spend
sleeping how much time do you want to
spend with family how much time do you
want to spend this will change right if
you're a husband wife single kids
anybody sick in their family those will
shift our calendar accordingly but right
now think about your life right now how
much time do you want to spend with your
family how much time you want to spend
in your business how much you want to
how much time you want to spend
do you need for yourself
free time or meditation time or working
out time or going out in nature time how
much time you want to spend planning
that as opposed to randomly hoping that
your day happens as you want it it's not
having no plan and no schedule is the
path to stress and overwhelm
having a decent plan even a poor plan at
the beginning starts to create the
momentum that you need so think about
how much time you want to spend in those
categories because you don't want to
spend all day sleeping you don't you
don't want to spend all day with your
family you don't want to spend all day
with your kids with your husband wife
you don't want to spend all day working
you don't want to spend all day relaxing
either like the idea of work sitting on
a beach might be great right now because
you feel stressed overwhelmed and may
hate your life but you don't want to
spend all day every day at a beach you
would get so bored the trick is not to
escape your current life because then
you're going back to it right so Escape
for two weeks the life that you hate to
then come back to it the trick is to
build a better life and it starts with
an intentional calendar so think about
how much time you want to spend on the
different categories
then step two I would split it up
between things that you need to do daily
and things you need to do either on a
weekly or monthly basis so daily is
daily routine so I have a morning
routine I'll wake up I'll put on music
I'll set the intention for the day I'll
go for a walk outside it's the snowing
in Toronto this morning I still go for
my walk outside I'll do some kind of
workout whether it's swimming or yoga
some kind of workout and then I'll start
my day
right what I do is start my day like my
business day those are different days of
the week okay so just do morning routine
and then evening routine so we bucket
these but these are mostly the same
every day evening routine
uh I'll eat dinner with Nina at six I
have blocked off an hour to be able to
spend time with her at seven I'll stream
on my gaming YouTube channel answering
questions from you at eight I'll spend
time with my son Hayden usually playing
Minecraft or catching up or doing
something together nine will sit down
and watch a show with Nina right now
we're watching Wheel of Time on Amazon
10 I'll take the dogs out I'll come back
up I'll clean the dishes and whatever
else needs to be cleaned in the condo 11
o'clock I'm getting ready for bed
reading the book and hopefully passing
out right evening routine pretty
structured pretty similar every day
what it does is make sure I have time
for all the stuff I want to have time
with my son I want to have time with my
wife I want to have time to eat dinner
and not be stressed out and rush into
the next thing I want to make sure that
there's still time to do the family
admin stuff like take the dogs out and
clean the place because sure if I miss
it one day everything would be fine but
if every day I'm not taking the dogs out
and not clean up the place that's going
to cause strain on my relationship with
Nina and also not being happy with
myself right so all these things are
designed now that structure may sound
overwhelming and crazy for you awesome
you have different goals maybe you need
four hours of open time every night or
four hours of meditation time every
night don't don't take my calendar I'm
just giving you an example you need to
create your calendar for yourself
so what's your daily morning routine and
daily evening routine put it down create
it
then inside of the week you might have
different different things on different
days I structure my entire day so Monday
is mentoring day I just Mentor my team
Tuesday is YouTube day where i'm filming
content today's a Tuesday I don't know
when the video comes out for you but for
me I'm filming on a Tuesday Wednesday is
my project day it's totally open to work
on projects that I want to work on
Thursdays public facing dates interviews
podcasts shows Etc so Tuesday Thursdays
are busy this I'm not being creative I'm
just work work work work work work work
work very little free time
and I'm doing tons of videos and tons of
interviews Wednesday in the middle is
totally open
like okay all the ideas that I've had
all the projects that I've wanted to do
here's my time in my calendar to do it
because if I didn't have that spot then
I would feel again stressed out
overwhelmed I feel like I'm just
answering all these messages and just
creating content and just going on
people's shows and I have no time to
create my own stuff perfect Wednesdays
Done Right Wednesdays I would use to
write my book
the whole day totally open Friday's my
CEO day
where I work on the business instead of
in the business Saturday is fun day
so Saturday if I'm doing anything that's
work related has to be cleared through
Nina first and better be something big
so I lose out on some opportunities
because Saturday is is fun day and then
Sunday is family at midday cleaning up
the condo grocery shopping
Costco whatever whatever needs to get
done that's my life
right that fits for me let me leave the
total worst thing for you it probably is
awesome figure out your life
morning routine evening routine your
entire life not just what you need to do
as an entrepreneur for your business but
for your life as a husband or a wife or
a son or a daughter or parent your life
time you need for yourself
create it
morning routine evening routine and then
the rest of the week what are you gonna
do
it matters this is how you start to
build consistent habits
the next step is to
evaluate at the end of the week how well
you did the whole point isn't to beat
yourself up of how you sucked and how
you missed this and schedules don't work
for you Etc but to evaluate it's not
that you can't stick to a schedule is
that the schedule wasn't a good enough
schedule for you
so what needs to change in the schedule
for example for dinner for me
these are these micro tweaks you might
have to make a big tweak but a micro
trick for me was I had my dinner from 5
30 to 6 with Nina
and it just felt too rushed because okay
well we don't usually take an hour to
eat we eat small meals so we usually eat
it pretty quickly
um so okay half an hour perfect easy
enough time
but it kind of felt rushed getting into
it so even though it doesn't take us a
full hour to eat I book off an hour to
eat that's an example of a micro
adjustment so think about where do you
feel stressed out in your calendar
you've done it for a week right you plan
out your calendar for the next week
perfect morning routine eating routine
what happens during the week during the
day perfect you evaluate at the end of
the week where did you feel stressed
where did it not work out
where did you miss something
and if it's a one-off thing okay fine
something happened but if it's happening
consistently
then your calendar is broken
then you need to spend more time here if
you get to the end of the week and you
feel stressed out overwhelmed what are
you feeling feel like oh I don't have
enough time to myself this is what the
the person I was mentoring yesterday
said like I look at your calendars I
couldn't do that I have no time to
myself
great scheduling time to yourself
because if you don't schedule in time
for yourself chances are something's
going to jump on top of it and you'll
never have time for yourself I'm giving
you the answer
so where is time for yourself
oh Saturday morning perfect how much
time you need four hours great put that
in give yourself five hours as a buffer
just in case now you got the time
and protect that time
so it's making those micro adjustments
as you go until your first week if
you've never done this or feels
overwhelming or stressed for you the
first week is probably going to be a
disaster that's okay
you did some of the things that's better
than not doing any of the things so
let's make some progress now at the end
of the week look back and iterate
change it make some micro tweaks okay
that clearly didn't work here okay so
next week I'm going to try doing this
and what you do is get closer and closer
and closer to creating a schedule that
actually fits for who you are for your
goals and it's not going to be my
schedule it's not going to be Steve
Jobs's schedule or Jordan Peterson
schedule anybody else it's gonna be one
that you designed tailored for you and
then the third last step to it is you're
going to grow and change as a person and
your schedule needs to change and adjust
alongside so there's a very big
difference between having a job and
being an entrepreneur there's also a
difference between being a solo
entrepreneur and then having a team does
it even having five people on your team
or one person to five people to
37 people now for me there's a big
difference in how I need to manage my
time I didn't I have a whole day
dedicated to mentoring I didn't need
that when it's just me
right things have to change if you're
single versus in a relationship or
single versus engaged versus married and
how long you've been married
or if you have kids or not or planning
to have kids right like your your
choices will change as you change as a
human so even if you create the perfect
schedule right now for yourself and
that's reflective of today like it's a
perfect schedule for this week right now
chances are in a couple months you're
gonna have to make some micro tweaks
because something's changed in your life
and that's okay that doesn't mean that
your schedule sucks just means it needs
an evolution as you evolve your schedule
has to evolve with you
you are what you consistently do and the
way to become that person that you want
to build the life that you want it's not
just having some
vision board for yourself
it's by actually putting into your
calendar let your calendar be your
bucket list
that if you start actually living this
life and doing these things it leads to
a happy whole life for you
treat your personal just as important as
your business
everything gets put into the calendar
and then adjust
and now you're building a life that you
want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to get rich in the new
economy check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there right now
the entire economy is shifted the last
century was a century about power and
when I say power I mean like energy the
wealthiest individuals of the last
century were built on oil the biggest
companies were all energy companies fast
forward today